you are so fantastic and funny on veep
and I feel like that's where I first
started to you know notice you and I
think a lot of people did too you got a
lot of fans from some in really high
places yeah yeah a lot of nice positive
feedback one day I got a letter a very
nice letter from Tom Hanks a letter in
the mail in the mail got home as a
letter from Tom Hanks and I opened up
and it was like the nicest sweetest
letter it was like I'm a big fan I like
I saw your work and I'm a huge fan can't
wait to see what you do next
I showed my friend my friend Jamie she
started crying you know like she's like
oh my goodness I I had it framed to put
it on my wall just like this letter from
Tom Hanks so I was at the Critics Choice
Awards in the night from across the room
I saw him in person and I was like oh my
goodness he's like hey get my letter oh
yes I did I did and I was like oh I
didn't write back I just got this letter
and I just put it on my wall like a
certificate of achievement yeah
it doesn't occur yeah it doesn't occur
to you that you got it right back
you should write back should if you're a
good person you do
you